hello everyone this next game I'm about
to show you was played in 1962 Soviet
team championship between the one and
only Russian nation Medina and Oleg
Chernigov and in my opinion the beauty
of this game can rival that of any game
in chess history well I'll have to show
it to you and then you can decide for
yourselves
Rishikesh Medina is white and
all-electronic of is black so let's see
this game Rasheed plays efore c5 Knight
to f3 knight c6 d 4c captures on d4
Knight captures and before the Sicilian
defense we have g6 Knight to c3 Bishop
to g7 Bishop to e3 Knight to f6 Bishop
to c4 black castles Bishop to b3 and if
you've seen my game between Bobby
Fischer and Rubin fine maybe you
remember that in this position Rubin
played in 92 a5 going for this
LightSquared Bishop and Fischer
destroyed it with this a 5 move but in
this game electronical chose a different
approach in this game Chernykh of plate
Knight g4 he decided to go for this dark
square Bishop on e3 and also he opened
up the attack on this knight on d4 so on
Knight to g4 an edge between of place
Queen captures in g4 Knight captures on
d4 and now Queen to h4 so Chernykh of
place Queen to a5 pinning that knight on
c3 and Rashid castles so in this
position we have Bishop to f6 and in
this position electronic of thought that
well Medina would probably realize that
this is a drawn position and he would
offer a draw so as the story goes
Jericho went for a walk and he was
enjoying his stroll and checking out
some of the other games and he thought
that well the only thing Nash Medina of
can play is probably Queen to h6 I'll
just repeat Bishop to g7 and again Queen
to h4 and I'll repeat Bishop to f6 and
if he plays something like Queen to g3
well then
has this idea of playing Quintus III and
after the Queen is captured then night
to be to check so we have King to ah-1
grabbing the Queen and this is better
for black as White's pawn structure is
all messed up but even if this is
playable for white it would still be a
very long drawn game probably so after
chernigov played this Bishop to f6 move
the story goes that Rashid was thinking
about the position for some 40 minutes
and a very excited boy ran off ran over
to Jericho and he said well mister he
sacrificed his Queen and as journey Cove
rushed back to the table he saw that
Rashid played Queen captures on f6 and
this is a move well I mean I always look
for these kind of moves and I don't
think I would I would I would play this
or even or even get an idea like this so
let's see how the game continues
obviously all-electronic of will accept
the Queen but first he plays an ITV to
check just to this coordinate White's
pieces for a bit so Knight captures an
e2 and only now he captures on f6 and
Rasheed brings his knight back Knight to
c3 and okay look at this position if you
ask an engine engine will say okay black
is better but okay you have your queen
on a5 is black but what has these two
bishops iron that King g8 and he has a
potentially very dangerous night that's
ready to jump to d5 nothing can oppose
him and blacks rooks are undeveloped his
bishop is still undeveloped and well
let's see how journey Cove handles this
so turning off plays rook e8 and Rasheed
defends this pawn on e4 actively he
plays Knight to d5 so now the phone can
be captured because of Knight f6 check
so Chernykh off plays rook to e6 and now
Rashid plays Bishop to d4 again going
for that f6 pawn so we have King to g7
defending the pawn and we have rook a to
d1 activating this rook so we have d6
preparing to develop the bishop and
Rashid plays rook to d3
prepares for a nice rock lift to f3
Bishop to d7 and now rook to f3 again
going for that f6 pawn so we had Bishop
to b5 attacking the rook on f1 but
Rashid first place rook Bishop to c3
attacking the Queen on a5 the Queen
moves to d8 to help with the defense of
the f6 pawn and now we have Knight
captures on f6 so we have Bishop to e2
and in this position well this was the
probably the losing move Bishop to e2 in
here black has to admit that he's not
better and that he should probably play
something like rook a to c8 and well
continue this game but he plays a Bishop
to e2 and after Bishop to e2 allows
Russian edge Medina to play this
beautiful move Knight captures on h7 and
what's the idea of Knight captures on f7
well if you look at this position if the
knight is captured then look at this
strong bishops diagonal and look at this
rook going to h3 it would be extremely
dangerous for black so or electronic of
plays King to d8 King to g8 and now
Rashid plays rook to h3 so we have rook
to e4 or lecture Nicole would love to
exchange this rook for this amazingly
strong dark squared bishop but Rashid
plays f4 he's not interested in the rook
so turning off plays Bishop captures an
f1 and King captures an f1 and still now
this rook is attacked on e5 by the pawn
so we have worked the c8 and now again
Rashid does not capture the rook with
the F pawn but he plays Bishop to d4
he's protecting this bishop like it's
made of gold so we have B 5 and now we
have Knight to g5 we have rook to c7
protecting that f7 pawn and this is
where Rashid goes all goes all out he
plays Bishop captures on f7 with Czech
rook captures on f7 and now we have R up
to h8 check King captures on nh8 and now
Knight captures an F
and forking the King the Queen and the
rook on e5
so King 2h7 Russia grabs the Queen and
d8 rook captures an e4 Knight to c6
protecting the bishop
rook captures an f4 would check King e2
and in this position all-electronic off
finally resigned and if you look at this
position White has two pieces for the
rook and he's also a pawn up but black
has three pawn islands and well it will
be it will be impossible to play this as
two pieces by themselves are stronger
than the rook and White's pawns are much
better
so yeah an amazing game and what an
amazing guy Rashid Najma Dean of love
Paula graves he said once that he beat
image Medina at least a dozen times but
the one game that he lost in as Medina
was so beautiful that he was trade all
of his 12 other games just to be on the
side of the board when Russia defeated
him to have those pieces and mikhail tal
once said that losing his game against
nature matheno in 1961 was probably the
best day of his life so yeah I don't
think I will ever do a video solely
about Russia tonight but you know as
like I always say you should all you
should check out a video made by Jessica
Fischer so type Jessica Fischer to
YouTube and check out her video about
Russian admit you know it's an amazing
video I'm sure you will enjoy it it's in
three parts so I think all in all it's
maybe 30 minutes long so yeah that was
that was the game well now you can tell
me if you agree that it's definitely one
of the most beautiful games ever played
and as usual you can check to my
previous videos here and I'll see you
soon